alors la première question qui vous
faisait ça va travailler en france
combien de personnes ont été tuées sur
les routes en bon son et non c'est 3684
l'année dernière soit un questionnaire
sur la sécurité routière pour
sensibiliser les automobilistes
celui-ci roulait à son km heure au lieu
de 80 pas de contravention aujourd'hui
mais de la pédagogie ce que ça fait
c'est bien ça fait réfléchir
non franchement je me tourne enfin je
pensais pas surtout que là j'ai bien
entre guillemets exagéré sur vitesse
donc
je pense fait du bénin sur cette route
départementale limitée désormais à 80
km/heure les gendarmes ont intercepté ce
matin une dizaine de véhicules
l'objectif de ces contrôles c'est de
convaincre de l'intérêt de cette mesure
en bessin la vitesse de 10 km ont gagné
13 mètres pour s'arrêter et ainsi on
réduit la gravité des accidents quels
que soient leur cause mais certains
automobilistes restent encore sceptiques
convaincus donc encore on verra d'ici
deux ans si la mesure a porté ses fruits
les réactions des gens aujourd'hui c'est
très intéressant de voir avec lesquels
on peut discuter ils ont exactement les
mêmes réactions qu'ont avec avec leurs
parents leurs grands parents lorsqu on
est passé dans les années 70 deux pas de
limitation du tous à 110 tout le monde
disait mais finalement ça sert à rien et
en fait on se rend compte que le nombre
de morts a diminué de manière
spectaculaire
lorsqu'il ya eu ce type de mesures
encore quelques semaines de tolérance et
de pédagogie avant d'être verbalisés
[Applaudissements]